i
am the creator
i am the permanent source
abide
as the source
abide as the immovable
the nature of reality can be
distilled through these very
simple explain like i'm five
visualizations and the more that we
refine it
down like this
in simplicity
the more we can harmonize
together as an enlightened civilization
recognize yourself as the absolute
recognize yourself as the creator
recognize yourself
as the source recognize yourself
as nothingness and
infinity
enlightenment is that
enlightenment awakening
is recognizing oneself
as the permanent source
recognizing oneself as the
absolute
you are that
i am that
tatvam asi i
and my father are one
only the ignorant seek what is already
there
yet it remains for you to recognize it
you go from room to room looking for the
diamond necklace that is already around
your neck
you are the absolute you are source
you are the permanent you are the
immovable
behind all of the transients
behind all of the impermanence behind
all of the creation
behind all of the names behind all of
the form
behind all of the layers of identity
behind your ethnicity
behind your career
behind all of the most
gross physical
there's a layer of subtlety
in identity when you move
away from the body
and you move towards
the formless you move towards
the subtle
you move towards awareness you move
towards
consciousness you move towards the
witness you move towards the
observer you move towards the seer
you are seeking that which is
seeing
[Music]
your very awareness itself
is that which you seek
like in the parable of the prodigal son
you go outward
seeking happiness and peace
and you hit a breaking point because you
can't extract it
from maya from the intoxication from the
illusion
you can't extract it from the world your
very awareness
is nature is peace and happiness
and that's why in the parable of the
prodigal son is to turn back
inward to investigate the very nature
of awareness itself
that's a step in subtleties to recognize
that diamond that is
already around your neck that is already
around
each of our necks the very impersonal
witness the very fact that the awareness
itself is
shared it is not a personal
awareness a personal consciousness
it is a shared witness a shared
consciousness a shared awareness
just look at the eye when you look at
the
eye what do you see you see the pupil
the pupil is what is shared
and the iris is the unique coloration
it's the unique
form it's the unique name it's the
unique
identity that the firework
of infinity gets to express itself as
again we never discount
the beauty of the individuated
firework it's gorgeous we celebrate it
we applaud it
yet there's a synthesis of
the western individuation
with the eastern unity
non-duality
because the ultimate the
absolute
as you gain even more
subtlety
as you gain even more
sensitivity in recognizing the
impersonal witness the impersonal
awareness
is like the sky that has
all of the transient clouds appearing
and disappearing
as the object's perceptions
sensations beliefs feelings
emotions
you recognize the sky itself is
impersonal
it's shared among us you begin
subtly holding the observation the
seeing that's happening beyond
just your perspective you begin
simultaneously holding
observation in two three
five ten a whole city
of people at the same time
until you get all the way up to being
able to hold all
8 billion units of awarenesses
perception simultaneously
that is the absolute
impersonal witnesses visualization
when you can hold that perception
you've attained an extremely high level
of subtlety
you've purified your mirror
significantly
very few people have purified their
mirror to that degree
many people reside the vast majority
reside in the egoic
separate entity a very dirty mirror
that very dirty mirror does not know its
true nature
that very dirty mirror when it looks at
another
it sees an actual separate entity
and it believes itself as a separate
entity which is the most
upstream root cause of
all suffering and misery
not knowing thyself
the delphic maxim written on the top of
the temple of apollo
at delphi know thyself
purify the mirror away from the separate
entity ego
i am not the body you have to negate
which is what is taught in the direct
path
teaching that first you have to negate
in order to know thyself in order to
know your source you have to negate
first and foremost in this direct path
to knowing thyself
you negate the body i am not the body i
am not
the thoughts i am not these clouds of
experience and sensation and perception
and beliefs and feelings and emotions
that arise and disappear
i am not my layers of identity all of
this form all of this
name i am none of that shed shed shed
negate negate negate
and as you do you purify your mirror
you purify it it's beautiful you shine
it you clean it
it becomes more pristine you no longer
see
another as a separate entity but you
recognize
love which is the very awareness that we
share
our being that's what true love
is
and as you do that you purify your
mirror
towards the state of impersonal
witnessing
you're able to hold that state of all 8
billion units
of perception simultaneously
that is the ultimate impersonal witness
here
in this creation for you to be able to
hold
as you do that you're really mastering
awareness you're mastering consciousness
you're mastering seeing
very few people have purified their
mirrors to that extent it is a very
subtle very formless
high level of being that
so at that point you're really deeply
experientially
recognized realized the diamond
around your neck and the diamond around
all necks and you're then
seeing through those diamonds
simultaneously
that's a whole beautiful
abiding that requires
a lot of silence it requires a lot
closing one's eyes and meditating
on that abiding as that very
absolute impersonal witnessing
and as you close your eyes and stay in
silence and abide
as that repeatedly you basically do the
gym
repetitions which
make it so that you no longer get
triggered
also by all of the egoic pyrotechnics
all of the dirty mirrors the vast
majority
trigger one another via egoic
pyrotechnics
and what the mystic traditions teach is
how to
use the breath
to create a pause so that you can be the
observer
rather than that which reacts
and then you watch the cloud arise and
pass
as the observer you purify your mirror
away from the egoic pyrotechnics to what
is more subtly known as the witness
to the awareness which is the sky in
which the clouds arise and pass
and then from there you work your way
outward to hold
two three five ten a whole city in the
whole planet as an impersonal witnessing
and then
in order to recognize the absolute in
order to
realize oneself as source
as nothingness and infinity
as god as tao as brahman in order to
recognize oneself as that absolute
pure white source light
one must even transcend
awareness itself
the most impersonal awareness
to transcend even that it is the last
attribute
source's first attribute is awareness
and the very last attribute as
you negate negate negate in this direct
path nettie nettie to your source
not this not that not the body not the
thoughts
not even the awareness and you
pluck out that very last attribute
the impersonal awareness
in silence deep meditation
with your eyes closed in the most subtle
most formless states possible
that's when you recognize source that's
when you recognize the absolute
you are that you are that which is
permanent you are that which is
immovable you are that which is eternal
that is your true nature i am the
creator
i am that you are that
we are just not subtle enough
to feel it we are not sensitive enough
to
feel our very infinitude
look around you everything is a fractal
that is secreting
that is you you are that
your very nature is the infinite
secretion
endless fireworks eternal
fireworks that is your very nature
the absolute immovable endlessly
expressing itself as all of these
gorgeous fireworks
you are already it you are the absolute
that's why in the second step in the
direct path after
all of the netty netty negation i'm not
the body i'm not the thoughts and i'm
not
even the impersonal witness i am the
source
once you get there via negation what do
you do after
in step two is to include
after negation is including i
am all i
am source and i'm also the impersonal
witness
and i'm also this unique character i'm
this unique
firework in this
fractal secretion that never ends
but you can only get to true inclusion
after going through honest earnest
negation earnestness is key
how badly do you want to know your
nature how badly do you want to purify
your mirror
suffering is the drill sergeant of
awakening
once the ego pyrotechnics in the
parable of the prodigal son gets so out
of
hand where the maya and the intoxication
pursuing peace and happiness externally
gets
so nasty
the sludge hammer comes no more tickling
with the feather
the drill sergeant of awakening
suffering comes with a sledgehammer
and it forces you to purify your mirror
it forces you to turn inward and
recognize
your true nature
respond to the feather respond as subtly
as you can as early as you can recognize
that your own source
realization is the most important
service that you can render humanity
it's the most important service you can
render
yourself your family your friends
your community and the planet is to
purify your own
mirror in recognizing your true nature
identity is the ultimate litmus test
are you the body
and all of its egoic pyrotechnics
are you the witness are you the observer
are you the seer
are you consciousness are you awareness
are you the sky
in which the clouds happen have you
gotten to at least that stage
watch the direct path videos on our
channel if you haven't we guide you
gently in the process to the stage
at least of recognizing yourself
as awareness purify your mirror at least
to that point
do you recognize yourself as the
impersonal
awareness that's a very high level of
subtlety
very few people have attained
and the more that do the more of an
enlightened civilization this will be
have you realized the absolute have you
realized yourself
as source
have you went all the way
to your true nature
and then have you included everything
afterward
again negate negate i am not the body i
am not the thoughts
i am awareness i am that which witnesses
i am the impersonal
observation i am not even
that which sees i am
only the impermanent immovable eternal
source white light which endlessly
refract through the prism
creating all of these gorgeous
endless creations fireworks
infinite form infinite identity
endless beauty
again the negation to source
and then the inclusion of all creation
identity is the ultimate litmus test you
know yourself a source
i am the creator i am the absolute
i am that
you are that
these very simple explain like i'm five
visualizations
are paramount
paramount for our future they're
paramount
for the children
that are coming in that are excited to
learn about their true nature
and bringing this into animated series
bringing this into
the virtual and augmented reality as a
pedagogy is really exciting
that is all i adore you
thank you
subscribe if you haven't to the channel
we'd love your support
like the video if it brought you value
please comment below
with your thoughts we'd love to hear
from you share the video
with those that you know this would very
positively
influence let's share it
share the essence of i am the creator
with more people to catalyze
that planetary awakening
to our own true nature
i am source i
am the permanent i am the immovable i
am the eternal
that is my true nature
thank you
you